نعم في الحقيقه الواقع جدا بات صعبا بعد
ان صرح الدفاع المدني بانهم توقفوا عن
عمليات البحث والانقاذ وانتقلوا الى
عمليات البحث والانتشار في هذه النقطه
الاقامه المؤقته التي هي خلفي منذ قليل
توجه عدد كبير من الشباب الذين هم كانوا
مقيمين في هذه الخيمه التوجه الى مدينه
جنديرس التي كانوا يقتلون بها للبحث وعن
ذويهم ومعرفه مصير ذويهم خمسه ايام لا
يعلمون عن ذويهم اي شيء كل يوم يتوجهون
الى المشفى ينظرون الى صور القتلى وينظرون
ويتنقلون بين جثث القتلى للبحث عن ذويهم
او معرفه مصيرهم ولكن الى الان لم يصلوا
الى معرفه مصيرهم وحالهم كحل كثير من سكان
المنطقه التي مناطق التي تضررت بشكل كبير
حقيقه تصريح الدفاع المدني
اثار الخوف لدى جميع الاهالي الذي ما زال
ذويهم تحت انقاض وان
ما زال لديهم الامل مهما مضى الوقت الاهل
يبقى لديهم الامل بخروج ابنائهم وذويهم
احياء من تحت الانقاض ولكن حقيقه الدفاع
المدني وحسب ما ذكر انها مضيء ايام على
الكارثه والعوامل الجويه والعوامل
اللوجستيه من المعدات وامكانيات لديهم قد
تضيع فرصه النجاح من تحت الانقاذ وكما
ايضا ذكرت فرق الدفاع المدني ان العجز
لديهم كان كبير جدا ولم يتوجه لديهم او لم
يتقدم لي ايديهم اي دعم لوجستي دولي او
فرق او تقديم فرق او دخول فرق للمساهمه
والمساعده ان كان لوجستيان كان بفرق لديها
خبرات او التجهيزات التي يمكن ان تساعد
حقيقه فرق الخبره الدفاع المدنيه رقم
خبرتها في رفع الانقاذ والبحث عن ناجيم
تحت الانقاض خلال السنوات الماضيه جراء
الحرب ولكن اليوم تقف امام عجز كبير امام
عدد كبير من المواقع التي تضررت تهدمت
فيها ابنيه واتحكم
والتعاون مع الفرق الاهليه وعناصر من
المقاتلين المعارضه المسلحه الذين تطوعوا
للعمل والبحث عن الناجين هذا من جانب
العمليات البحث والمقاضي ولكن من الجانب
الاخر عمليات الاغاثه وعمليات الانسانيه
هي جدا شحيحه هناك العمليات الاغاثيه هي
من قبل المنظمات المحليه العامله في
الداخل السوري
تتواصلنا مع كثير من المنظمات عن امكانيه
هل سيكون هناك خيام او مخيمات سيتم
انشائها التضرر جراء هذا زلزال ليتم
استقبالهم فيها واقامتهم في هذه المقيمات
بعد ان فقدوا منازلهم او منازلهم باتت
متصدعه ولا يمكن السكن فيها قالوا لنا ان
حتى الان ليس لديهم الامكانيات على انشاء
مخيمات جديده وامكانياتهم محدوده وتقتصر
على تقديم بعض المساعدات
والانسانيه لهذه النقاط والاهل الذين
تضرروا من اغطيه وبعض الخيام وليس الكثير
منها لانهم ايضا ليس لديهم الكافي من
القيام الاستيعاب هذه الماساه الكبيره
وهذا العدد كبير من المتضررين هذا من
الجانب الانساني اما من الجانب المساعدات
الانسانيه يوم امس دخلت قافله مساعدات
انسانيه مقدمه من كردستان العراق دخلت الى
الاراضي السوريه وهي تحويل بعض المساعدات
الانسانيه من الاغذيه واغطيه
وبعض المساعدات الطبيه توجهت الى مدينه
جنديرس لتقدم الى الاهالي المتضررين حتى
الان الكارثه كبيره جدا الاعداد كبيره جدا
ما تزال لم تتكشف بكامل هذه الصوره
الاعداد الكبيره والاهالي ينظرون الى
متشتتون بين معرفه مصير ذويهم تحت
الانقراض ومعرفه مصيرهم هم الى اين سيكون
المصير هل سيكونون في مخيمات ام سيعودون
الى منازل ام تبدا معاناه فصل من معاناه
جديده في حياتهم